حجم هذه الوحشية
غير مسبوق حقًا،
هجوم غير مسبوق على الإطلاق، هذا غير مسبوق تمامًا
هنا، الصراع بين إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين ليس جديدًا في الواقع، فهو
مستمر منذ ما قبل
تأسيس إسرائيل في عام
1948، فلماذا يعتبر هجوم حماس الأخير على
إسرائيل
غير مسبوق إلى هذا الحد؟  مفاجأة
الهجوم في 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)، أطلقت حماس
وابلاً من الصواريخ باتجاه إسرائيل بينما
دخل مسلحون إلى إسرائيل من غزة.
لم تشهد إسرائيل هذا النوع من التسلل
إلى القواعد العسكرية والبلدات في كيبيت في
تاريخها الذي يعود إلى 75 عامًا، ومن المعروف أن البلاد تمتلك
واحدة من أكبر الدول في العالم.  القوات المسلحة الأكثر إثارة للإعجاب،
وهي وكالة استخبارات رائدة وأمن
حدود متطور، ولكن
يبدو أن هذا الهجوم فاجأهم، حيث
قالت الولايات المتحدة إنهم لم يتلقوا أي
معلومات استخباراتية على المستوى التكتيكي تفيد
بحدوث هجوم بهذا الحجم في هذا اليوم،
وقال مسؤول استخباراتي أمريكي كبير لشبكة
CNN إن  أثارت قدرة حماس على
تنسيق الهجمات على البلدات الإسرائيلية
دون اكتشافها مخاوف
بشأن النقاط التكنولوجية العمياء بالنسبة
للاستخبارات الأمريكية، وثانيًا شدة
الهجوم. وقالت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
إنه تم إطلاق أكثر من 5000 صاروخ
من قطاع غزة منذ
7 أكتوبر لوضع ذلك  في السياق عام
2021، خلال الحرب التي استمرت 11 يومًا مع حماس،
تم إطلاق حوالي 4300 صاروخ في أعقاب
هجوم يوم السبت، أعلنت إسرائيل رسميًا
الحرب على حماس، وهو
الإعلان الأول من نوعه منذ 50 عامًا، مما يمهد
الطريق لعملية عسكرية كبيرة في
غزة، حيث تقاتل القوات الإسرائيلية
مسلحين في جنوب البلاد.  إسرائيل
تقصف غزة بضربات جوية
[موسيقى]
في اليوم الثالث للصراع،
قُتل أكثر من 900 شخص في إسرائيل
بينما قالت السلطات في غزة إن أكثر من 680
شخصًا قتلوا في
القطاع الفلسطيني في 9 أكتوبر،
إسرائيل التي تسيطر على معظم
الواردات
أمرت إسرائيل بفرض حصار كامل على
القطاع الفلسطيني من السلع الأساسية، ولن يتم
توصيل الكهرباء أو الماء أو الوقود إلى هناك،
وأخيرًا وضع الرهائن تقول حماس
إنها تحتجز أكثر من 100 رهينة في
غزة، وتدعي المجموعة أن هذا يشمل
ضباطًا رفيعي المستوى في الجيش ولكن
ويشمل أيضًا النساء وكبار السن والأطفال.
منذ أكثر من 17 عامًا، تم
احتجاز جندي إسرائيلي كرهينة في هجوم
على أراضي البلاد، وتقول حماس إن
الرهائن محتجزون الآن في
مواقع في جميع أنحاء غزة، مما قد
يعقد رد إسرائيل على
الهجوم المميت الذي شنته الجماعة المسلحة.